mike is with us hey mike how are you hey
better than i deserve dave thank you
sure how can i help sure uh so i have a
question for you uh
i did something a few months ago that i
know you would advise against
but uh it was before i found your
podcast so don't be mad at me
i'm not mad at you it didn't hurt me
that's true
so i did a cash out finance uh when the
rates went real low
and i was able to drop my mortgage rate
uh over a full point
and i figured hey while i'm at it why
not take out some extra cash to have
but uh you know now i have this extra
debt that i have to carry so my question
is
should i go ahead and repay this thing
back and pretend like it never happened
or should i try to invest it um i got it
at a pretty low rate
and just trying to see what i should do
with it
well i agree with you i wouldn't have
done that but now we're there
so we're not gonna we're that's water
under the bridge that milk is spilled
so um so you're out of debt except this
home
uh no i'm on baby steps four five and
six um
that's what i mean yeah you're out of
debt except the home yep
and you've got your emergency fund in
place and you're already putting 15
not counting this money and so
regardless of where the money
came from if you have a pile of money
and you're in four five and six
you would say you're going to use it on
four five and six four is underway
you have children yes okay is there
college fund underway
oh yeah it sure is uh you know still
saving towards it but they have a good
amount for themselves okay
then baby step six is pay off the house
early right
right exactly and so we would use if you
got a bonus equal to the amount in your
savings in excess of your emergency fund
you would throw it at the house wouldn't
you
yes it would yeah so i just throw it at
the house yeah the problem with you know
i mean my thing was the closing costs
were about 20
000 so i feel like i'm just basically
you know kind of throwing that money
away uh
yeah every time i do something stupid
and it costs me money i call it stupid
tax
yeah but that you can't get that money
back
no that's true i just uh you know i just
what i did was i put the money in a
mutual fund for now
um to try to let it go someone hadn't
really had it it doesn't matter
that's just not that's not a path that
people use to build wealth it doesn't
work
and so we don't you know never
i've never talked to a millionaire said
i borrowed on my house as much as i
could possibly borrow my entire life and
i refinanced it often and took cash out
and put it in a mutual fund and that
made me rich i've never talked to a
single millionaire that told me they did
that
yeah so it's not it's not a methodology
that works so
even though it's a very costly mistake
that that cost is even under
you can't undo the cost so the only
question is now do you want to invest in
mutual funds or do you want to work our
plan
and work your baby step six that's the
only question you've got
and then you've got to decide that but
if it's me obviously my plan the thing
we teach here at ramsey is
we'll put excess cash that you've got
that's non-retirement funds from any
source
onto the house and pay it off as soon as
possible well and mike i think you know
that
i think you know that probably by
listening to the show and
what i would guess dave and maybe this
is just a hunch but sometimes we
i've done this in my life with whenever
i made a mistake with money is i resist
doing something that's going to make me
face the fact that i lost that money so
it's like putting it back on the house
makes me kind of face the fact that
it's the 20 000. so i'd rather put it
over here because then i can sort of
sideways justify that it wouldn't
totally maybe i think i figured out a
way to make it
turn the other way and pretend that 20
000 didn't happen if i put it back on
the house it's like oh i've got to
totally face it let's just
face it mike it is it happened bite the
bullet put it in the house and just
move on band-aid off you're right you're
right that's exactly what it is it's
emotionally
yeah you got to admit it but it's like
um you know
uh when you when you the car's gone down
in value
i don't know whether to sell it well
it's gone down in value
when you sell it you admit it right you
know
that's it that's the same kind of thing
that's the same issue exactly
you nailed that well done